[Music]
let's go to david in richmond virginia
what's up d-money
hey what's going on dr john just rocking
on to the break of dawn my brother
what's up i hear you man um i'm trying
to see if you can point me in the right
direction of
establishing some boundaries between
work
relationships and with my wife and just
trying to
find some direction man um
so i work from home i run my own
business and
i feel that
right now it's kind of difficult because
i am here all day long my wife's a
stay-at-home mom with our eight month
old
so
it's like i'm accessible i'm available
all the time but
if i'm available all the time i can't
work and make money
can't make money can't pay bills
have you all sat down while i'm reaching
out no it's i mean what you're
experiencing i've heard all over the
country for the last especially those
few years man and so hey no you're not
alone a b no
there is some
some pretty clear path forward okay
um
have you had that conversation with her
yes
it didn't go well huh
uh it really uh
it really doesn't okay tell me about it
well you know i just i sat down with her
and i said honey uh
you know i'm i'm trying to
provide for the family i'm trying to get
us out of
your parents house i'm trying to help
our future grow you live with your
parents you live with your in-laws
yeah so
just a little uh quick synopsis is
i had a job opportunity
in florida so i established a connection
down there and i
told this person hey you know if
everything is serious then i'll pursue
it he said yep everything's good
so i quit my job i was running my side
business
and i quit my full-time job sold the
house we planned to live with my in-laws
for a month or so
until we could find a place down there
move down there and start up down there
well he called me after i quit my job
and said hey uh
this opportunity
has come and gone with another person
filling that role oh man
all right
here we are so you moved how long have
you all been in your mother-in-law's
house
uh we've been here since december so
four or five months is she pumping your
wife full of well he should be
or is it a good place to be
it's it's not a bad place to be um
there's some negativity just with their
personality types um
well just sleeping with your wife in her
parents house is weird man you know i
mean like that's just strange
do you have kids too
yes we have eight months old oh my gosh
okay
so tell me what an like what a normal
well let me back up
you had this conversation you said hey
i'm trying to i need to put some put
some boundaries around my work day and
she said no
she said no
well she said
she told me i'm i'm trying to
stay out of your hair i'm trying to let
you be out there let you work
i don't know if
the fact that i get up at
four o'clock every morning and come out
here and work before her and our
daughter gets up
if that's taking a toll on her you know
not waking up beside her
that kind of stuff i i don't know and
then staying out here until five o'clock
in the evening
i don't know if it's
she just misses me throughout the day
um that'd be kind of cool
if she did right yeah i mean
and it is i
i think it's great that you know we have
that connection where she does miss me
throughout the day
so i'm missing something here i'm
missing something here so she come out
and bothering you or knocking on the
door or interrupting you saying hey i
need you to cut the yard or hey can you
watch the baby while i go do a thing and
you're in the middle of
a project of some sort
yeah so it
this is this is kind of how the daily
routine goes um it's pretty much down to
it see
so i'll get up about four o'clock i'll
go take a shower come outside go to work
um i'm working what are you working on
thirty eight o'clock uh
i do welding and fabrication okay
so you're just cranking you're just
you're just getting it done
i'm rolling okay
and
about at 7 30 8 o'clock i go inside
help her get her daughter get our
daughter up um
and then
you know i'll have me some breakfast and
come back out and that generally will
run until about eight thirty nine
o'clock
um
at night about 10 30
uh no that's just the morning okay
10 30 she'll come out here and visit me
then i turn around i'm back in at you
know 12 o'clock eating lunch and then
she's out here multiple times throughout
the day and
i'm just
i'm trying to find that balance of hey
honey let me work or hey honey um
you know i'm trying i'm in the middle of
something i can't just stop what i'm
doing and
come inside for
three hours at a time i can't just even
though i'm self-employed
i can't just not work
for an entire afternoon and go shopping
with you right
so how so how much of this do you feel
guilt and how much of this do you feel
is actual pressure
um
as far as the pressure
what do you mean
meaning
if she swings by and says hey do you
want to come you're going to run the
grocery store with us we're about to all
go
you look around and you're covered in
sweat you got your face shield on you're
in the middle of bending something and
you're like
i mean what about what's happening right
now makes you think i want to go to the
grocery store
and then you feel guilty like well i
guess i should probably be going to the
store so you know i mean how much of
that is her just trying to reach out and
be a human and you're taking on the
burden of this versus
her saying you can never go with me why
can't you ever go you're just sitting
here all day right which one of these is
is the truth
uh for me it's more
it's more the fact that i feel like i'm
letting her down by not spending time
with her and there you go that's my work
day too a job this
is my guess is this is on you
as much if not more than is on her and i
don't say that in a negative way just
saying
you've got you're the one that's at home
and you're struggling with being there
and withholding boundaries so here's an
easy thing right outside the studio door
is a red light and there's a switch that
goes right inside and they flip it
whenever we're recording so everybody
knows not to come in here
i want you to go to home depot and
you're handy enough you can do this in
30 minutes and get a switch and a bulb
and a red bulb and put on the outside of
your shop
and when you go into work i want you to
flip it on and it's red and i want you
to sit down with her and say
when this red light's on that means i'm
unavailable
when it's off then i'm working on
something i'm sitting down i'm drawing
up i'm i i'm in a position where if you
swing by i can talk to you
and then i want you to begin drawing
boundaries around your work day because
you're getting up at 4am you're working
till nighttime and you're coming in at
various moments here and there which is
confusing for everybody i want you to
have an on time and an off time and when
you're off at whatever time be off at
whatever time and then be fully present
most families i'm talking to across the
country are drowning from the toggling
i'm at home at the table but i'm at work
on my phone
right i'm sitting in the kitchen while
my wife's cooking but my head is
actually trying to solve a problem at
work and she's talking and i'm only
hearing half of what she's saying
and then she feels like i'm not paying
attention to her and then she
internalizes that and then she gets
frustrated then i internalize that
frustration and i get see what i'm
saying it becomes this gap so keep these
words in your mind be wherever you are
when you're in the shop turn it on and
off give yourself a work day as though
you are
um your own boss
you got to be in the shop running and
gunning by 4 30 you get off at 7 30 for
your first hour break
and you get an hour until 8 30. and then
from 8 30 until noon you're cranking for
three and a half hours and you get from
12 to one off and then you go until six
or til five and then you're off see what
i'm saying
and then sit down with your wife and say
here's these are going to be this is
going to be my schedule
and
own what you've got to own and then let
go of the other stuff you see what i'm
saying you got to find some balance
there unless you're in a season where
you're starting your own business you're
trying to grind from scratch
because somebody yanked the wool out
from under you
and this is just a season of six months
or 18 months or two years where
man is 24 7 365 i'm just trying to build
a book of business and i'm going and i'm
going and i'm going and i'm going is
that where you are too
it
i'm in between that phase right now i'm
i'm at a crossroads as well with my
business um between either you know
taking it 100
and
just cranking this business up to what
it can be
and
or
going and getting a day job to be able
to even qualify
for a mortgage
because self-employment is two years of
history
and i'm not trying to live in my in-laws
house for
another year and a half you can go rent
a house just fine
yeah and that's the discussion that me
and her have had and
you know what kind of areas and stuff
like that and that's
that's the other part that i'm i'm kind
of struggling with is brother but listen
don't overthink it just go run a house
it's not where you're gonna live forever
it's gonna be for six months or it's
gonna be for a year or go get a
two-bedroom apartment man it's not your
in-laws house
if you can afford it go get it done
and well what about the schools and what
about that man you got an
eight-month-old
right you'll figure out the that's
that's why we tell people to rent
because you'll find out in short order
is just a community you want to live in
or do you want to go find somewhere else
to live further away closer and you know
off top of your head whether you want to
run this business or you wouldn't get a
job you know that
and i would tell you to quit
dyson either way like i don't know just
jump in and if it's going to be working
on this business
get with a crew i'll send you a couple
of books real quick um not real quick
but i'll send you a couple of books i
want you to read i'm gonna send you
entree leadership by old man by dave
ramsey and i'm gonna send you ken
coleman's book from paycheck to purpose
it's gonna walk you through the the
blueprint for
going to get a job in a strange city
that you just in state that you just got
dropped off in and it's gonna provide
you a path towards running your own
small business either way you're gonna
have to have a road map but i'm gonna
i'm gonna provide you with either road
map okay
but you just gotta pull the trigger and
go do it
when it comes to boundaries at home go
get a light and turn it on and off and
be very clear here's my new work
schedule type it out on a piece of paper
print it up let her speak into it and
then let this be this
and there's gonna be some like is he
really serious about this i don't know
what do you think
there's gonna be some awkwardness and
some uh i told you
that's fine that's to be expected but
you're gonna live by this work schedule
right and then man guys get your own
place
it's time get your own place